problema número 190 la operación
estrella está definida para todas y ve
como estrella ve igualada cuadrada por b
entre 3 cuál es el valor de dos
estrellas entre paréntesis 3 estrella
menos 1 pues vamos a sustituir lo vamos
a hacer primero esta parte de acá y nos
dicen que 3 estrellas menos uno es igual
aquí la va a ser mi 3 y la b va a ser mi
menos 1 así que aquí voy a sustituir
donde encuentre una un 3 y donde
encuentre una vez un menos 13 al
cuadrado
ve que es menos solo entre 3 y vamos a
desarrollar esto es igual a 3 al
cuadrado 3 por 3 9 por menos 1 es menos
9 entre 3 y lo podemos simplificar como
menos menos 3
esto es esta parte de acá vamos a hacer
la operación con esto que falta tenemos
que es menos 3 por lo que es 2 estrellas
- 3 y hacemos lo mismo sustituimos donde
encontremos la vamos a poner un 2 y
donde haya b vamos a poner menos 3
tenemos que es 2 al cuadrado por b menos
tres entre 3
y aquí la entrada puedo ver que estos
dos se van me queda el signo de menos y
esto es menos 2 al cuadrado es 4 y mi
resultado es menos 4 que es la opción
siguiente problema las dimensiones
interiores de una caja rectangular son 6
x 8 x 10 un contenedor cilíndrico se va
a poner dentro de la caja quedando de
manera vertical con la caja apoyada en
una de sus seis caras de todos los
contenedores que podrían crearse cuál
será el radio en centímetros del que
tenga el máximo volumen vamos a dibujar
la caja más o menos para darnos una idea
de qué se trata esto nos dicen que es
una caja rectangular
qué voy a yo a dibujar más o menos así
rápidamente
arriba
más o menos no está muy exacta pero
bueno el chiste es que si dan una idea
que esta es la caja y ahora te voy a
indicar las dimensiones las dimensiones
son 10 6
y 8 pensemos en cuál es el volumen de un
cilindro el cilindro es algo así más o
menos
y tiempo
ahora sí que es una cara circular
y una altura
el volumen de un cilindro se va a medir
por el radio de su base
su radio
y por la altura que es más o menos está
de acá y le voy a llamar h el volumen es
el área de destacar a por su altura
el área de esta cara espí por radio al
cuadrado el volumen es pi por radio al
cuadrado por la altura a que será igual
r si vemos la base de la caja si
dibujamos esta base de la caja así vista
desde arriba un lado mide 6
el otro mide 8
en este caso el diámetro máximo va a
poder ser de 6 y por lo tanto el radio
sólo podrá ser de 3 es decir no puedo
hacer algo más grande aquí ya que este
lado de 6 me lo limita entonces mi radio
es de 3 aquí aunque desperdiciamos toda
esta parte de acá
la otra posibilidad es usar la caja con
la cara o el lado de 8 y de 10
bueno aquí nos que habría una base
circular pues más grande
esta tendría un radio de 44 regresando a
la fórmula del volumen para tener un
máximo volumen que deberíamos maximizar
la altura o el barrio bueno vemos que el
radio está al cuadrado por lo que este
elemento aumentará nuestro volumen más
que la altura así que el radio óptimo es
el de 4 ya que nos va a aumentar más el
total del volumen en la tercera opción a
la considero porque sería la cara que es
más pequeña de un lado y más ancha del
otro la cara que tiene 6 en un lado 6 y
10 porque tendría un círculo con un
radio de 3 o diámetro de 6 pero la parte
que se desperdicia más es
tiene una mayor área que se desperdicia
toda esta parte de acá es por eso me la
considera comparemos los volúmenes de
los dos primeros este le llamamos el
volumen 1 es igual al radio de 33 al
cuadrado es 9 pi por 9 y en este caso la
altura va a ser de 10
esto va a ser igual a 90 y 90 y en este
caso el volumen 2 es igual a pi por el
radio que es 4 al cuadrado es 16
la altura que va a ser de 6 este será 6
x 6 36 6 x 6 7 8 9 96
y si comparamos estos volúmenes esta
cantidad es mayor que ésta por lo que
este volumen 2 es el que es mayor el
máximo volumen y esta es mi opción
correcta que es la opción b
siguiente problema tenemos que resolver
todo esto y esta es una aplicación de lo
que seguramente ya vieron en álgebra
esto que es más b
por a menos b - b
que es igual a cuadrada menos b cuadrada
lo cual es algo bueno de saber para
hacer las cosas más rápidas vamos a
aplicarlo al ejercicio
primero resolver esta parte de aquí y
luego esta otra parte de acá
esto es a esto es de raíz de 2 al
cuadrado me va a quedar como 2 menos
de es 11 al cuadrado es 121 esta parte
me va a quedar así
2 - 1
esta sección de acá y esta otra sección
aplicamos esta parte y lo voy a poner en
otro color
va a ser raíz cuadrada de 3 y va a ser 1
raíz cuadrada de 3 al cuadrado va a ser
igual a 3 - 1 al cuadrado 1 así que todo
esto me queda 2 - 1 por 3 - 1
vamos a hacer estas multiplicaciones 2
por 3 6 2 por menos 1 - 2 - 1 por 3 - 3
- 1 por menos uno es más 1 y esto a su
vez es igual a 6 menos 5 16 menos cinco
más uno es igual a 2 que es mi opciones
siguiente problema en cierta clase de
cálculo la proporción entre los que
estudian matemáticas y los que no es de
25 si se agregan dos estudiantes de
matemáticas a la clase la proporción
será 1 a 2 la pregunta es cuántos
estudiantes hay en la clase vamos a
escribir los datos que nos dan los
estudiantes de matemáticas con respecto
a los que no estudian matemáticas es
igual a 2 a 5 o 2 entre 5 luego nos
dicen que se agregan dos estudiantes que
estudian matemáticas así que aquí está
m2 entre el mismo número de estudiantes
que no estudian matemáticas y ahora la
proporción es 1 a 2 o un medio nos
preguntan el total de alumnos que es el
número de estudiantes de matemáticas más
los que no estudian matemáticas esta es
nuestra incógnita y aquí tenemos dos
ecuaciones con dos incógnitas hagamos
una multiplicación cruzada en este caso
voy a multiplicar 5 por m
que es igual a n por 212 n
y lo mismo hago con esta otra ecuación 2
por m2 va a ser igual a 2 m
igual a n por 1 n estã n la sustituimos
aquí en esta primera ecuación entonces
me va a quedar 5 m es igual a 2 por m
pero m es
2 m 4
desarrollamos todo esto y nos va a
quedar 5 m es igual a 4 m 8 restamos 4 m
en ambos lados 5 m menos 4 m igual a 8 y
aquí m es igual a 8
y con esto ya podemos encontrar en los
institutos acá n va a ser igual a 2 por
mms 8
+ 4 igual a 8 por 2 16 más 420 m es
igual a 20
y ahora sumamos m n
ms 8 n es 20 nos queda que la clase
tiene 28 estudiantes que es mi opción d
siguiente problema cuál es el dígito
unitario de 13 a la cuarta 17 al
cuadrado y 29 al cubo aquí tienen que
darse cuenta que el dígito unitario de
cualquiera de estos números es el dígito
unitario de ellos elevado a sus
respectivas potencias y luego
encontramos el dígito unitario de su
multiplicación así que es lo mismo que
para encontrar el dígito unitario
hacemos 3 a la cuarta por 7 al cuadrado
por 9 al cubo y seguimos la misma lógica
sé que aquí 3 es igual a 3
es al cuadrado es igual al 93 al cubo sé
que bueno es algo pero me interese el
último dígito que termine en 7 y 3 a la
cuarta es igual a algo que termine no lo
aquí se lo estoy mostrando los dígitos
unitarios e ignorando los demás 7 al
cuadrado es igual a algo que termine el
99 al cuadrado es igual a algo que
termine en 19 al cubo es igual a algo
que termina en 9
ahora tomando estos últimos dígitos o
los dígitos unitarios de acá los
multiplicó 1 por 9 por 9 es igual a 9
y el dígito que me interesa es 1 y esta
es la opción
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo